new collaboration is fast okay woman sir
: yeah don't worry they've been at sea
for days with no idea where they'll end
up this is the moment seventy-three
migrants were rescued by open arms a
Spanish charity boats there packed
rubber dinghy was found around 70
kilometers off the Libyan coast after
its engine broke down among them is
five-year-old Ibrahim he'd made the
journey from Nigeria with his parents
they're all safe now but the seas
extremely rough with waves of up to 3
metres and while they're trying to make
it an adventure for Ibrahim for his mum
it's been traumatizing I was afraid I
didn't know the sea would be like this
if I knew I wouldn't have come I would
have gone back to my country the cruise
tried and failed to get permission to
land in Italy or Malta they say Italian
officials suggested the ship should dock
at the Libyan port of Tripoli for
Abraham's father that's not an option I
wanted to come to Europe he says it
wasn't easy but I said if I have to die
on the water it's better than returning
to Libya
I'd rather die at sea I really don't
want to return to Libya he must be in
door work door but we continue to ask
for a safe port to disembark which is a
legal obligation for the government
according to international conventions
we have people on board who probably
need to be evacuated due to health
issues Italy has allowed another group
of migrants onto its shores on Saturday
its Coast Guard saved 149 people from a
sinking boat near the island of
Lampedusa but survivors said up to 20
people were unaccounted for and several
bodies have already been recovered
according to the International
Organization for Migration there have
been nearly a thousand confirmed deaths
on the three main migration routes
across the Mediterranean this year
Nadeem barber al Jazeera